what do you think about this Kanye Kanye
running suppose that spirity Capote no
actually supposedly he actually entered
in and filled some paperwork for twenty
twenty four twenty I don't know I don't
know if this is confirmed but I saw it
floating around I think it may be BS but
he announced he's running for president
I am he's talking about twenty four but
the reason I bring this up now is
because there's a lot of people that are
upset I'm hearing people are upset that
it's gonna steal Biden's votes right
from the black community right and now
it's funny because different people are
getting angry at it for different
reasons right okay so we got people on
the Left that are like how dare these
racists say this they're so racist to
think that that the black vote belongs
the black vote belongs to Biden that
they would just you know assume that
just because Kanye's in they're gonna
take it it's like black lives matter
activists who are saying this yeah how
dare you right have to vote for Biden
right what's that assumption it's but
they're claiming that the Republicans
are saying that it's the Republican side
that's making that argument in place
there say they're mad at the Republicans
that's true though there are a lot of
Trump supporters who are saying that
Kanye running will take votes away from
Biden because Trump's base is not gonna
leave Trump right know exactly what it's
and and the people who are voting for
Biden there was that poll that we talked
about on Friday that they're not even
voting for Biden they're voting against
Trump yeah so it it has nothing to do
with with Biden really it's just that
they don't want to vote for Trump here's
those here's they would rather choose
Kanye over piden there was a there was a
poll put out by political polls on
Twitter mm-hmm and they just track all
the different polling and they said if
you were voting today who'd you pick
Trump by a Biden or Kanye it was Trump
in first place then Biden then Kanye and
the way I see it as I think Kanye steals
Volt's votes from both yeah I can see
that but because Trump has the hardcore
pro-trump base they have abandoned him
absolutely his advantage I agree because
people because Biden has no supporters
he just has anti Trump people like of
course there are some Biden supporters
but come on
yeah he got what six people to show up
to like one of his that I'm not kidding
every time I think about that image
he did a couple live streams that only
got a few hundred people I know it
sounds insane neither it not no one in
this room right now is running for
office and we had what like 56,000
people watching it's like if we can do
that and we're not interested in leading
anyone's live right that's really bad
Wow
so here's an apple but the news was
adamant about making sure everyone knew
that a million people didn't show up and
tell us it's like okay great but how
many people showed up for Biden Biden is
literally hiding the Diceman spare me
your concerns there's a lot of reasons I
think I think it's cause for concern
that Trump couldn't muster the numbers
he thought he was gonna monster that's
fine they don't they don't seem to
understand though that they push that
hoax about tik-tok kids you know it's
like it's a first-come first-serve event
it's like you walk in the door you get
in the event is there's different
reasons for why it didn't work out but
when I when I when I look at Kanye
running mm-hmm there are regular people
who will be for Kanye and that's the
real risk I'm honestly I'm interested to
hear his platform I want to hear I you'd
vote for him even though his policy and
it's like I want to know what he's
talking about it was policies okay
so yeah I do and I didn't say I will I
said I would
meaning semantics no no let me clarify
literally what I mean you go based on
the things kinda already said I would
give him my vote Tinka with some
prerequisites hmm I didn't say I'm going
to or I will or I plan on it sure I'm
saying that the doors not closed for
Kanye West a lot of people are gonna
look at Kanye and say it's ridiculous
why would you vote for him no no no no
yeah I would I would he's got a lot to
do he's smart dude
first of all Kanye is an urban liberal
yeah you grew up in Chicago he talks
about social justice issues I can dig
that yeah and then he also talks about
helping the American worker bringing
jobs back and he talks a lot about
things Trump has proposed that this man
Khan you might be a unity candidate yeah
okay Chicago urban liberal black man
yeah who understands those issues has
concerns for support in the black
community and is all about helping the
American worker and where's the manga
hat that dude will win in a landslide
I'm not kidding no I agree yeah when
when he speaks people listen especially
in the black community and if Kanye
comes out he runs I think he would he
would you just crush it yeah he would
win could you imagine if you ran the
Democratic ticket with a mug a message
but having like a more moderate liberal
approach yeah I think the DNC would
don't don't they don't want that though
they couldn't stop Kanye West no I know
but first lady that's right he would be
an independent he's not gonna run as a
Democrat
the DNC would be like nope sorry yeah we
cannot control you I'm sorry so so
there's a funny post where they were
like some I camera but it was but
somebody was ragging on no they weren't
ragging on Kanye they brought up the
absurdity okay and then someone said
like a celebrity candidate whose wife is
famous for like smut and stuff like this
and it's like basically describing Kanye
and Trump okay that's why it's like I
believe if Kanye ran as a Democrat he
would win hands down across the board
because KY is gonna have the social
justice message and the American worker
Mogga message that's true not perfectly
Republicans don't overwhelmingly support
Kanye I don't think that me whatever
yeah I don't think the DNC would have a
choice
they were just he would be Kanye walking
in the room and be like taking the mic
this is mine now I'm not gonna let you
finish I'm taking this and I'm gonna go
be President peace he would win I think
and people underestimate him yeah that's
a big mistake when I went when he first
started talking about Trump and Candace
Owens and stuff
I do research man I was reading what
what young black men were saying you
know there were arguments on Twitter
where young black men were saying things
like I got you Kanye like yo Kanye's was
all about you know I'm glad you're glad
you're speaking up a lot of people
saying things like they didn't know
about Trump they didn't f around with
him but Kanye said it and so they
started looking into it now they're down
and there are a bunch of black women who
were like don't listen to Kanye man is
no he's talking about and seeing these
arguments was really interesting that
Kanye you know look man some people
might look at him the establishment
elites will mock and belittle him the
same they did same thing they did to
Trump okay ignoring what he's what he's
all about you know Kanye is very much
like Trump in a lot of ways I can see
that he's he's a he's an intelligent
businessman now you can call him
eccentric and crazy but the Duke clearly
knows what he's doing any smarter than
you yeah
I don't see you becoming a billionaire
that dude has Got Talent yeah yes now
maybe he does something's wrong but I
think it's stupid people think Donald
Trump's a [ __ ] I'm like dude come on
man you can criticize the guy because he
became a billionaire off of a million
dollars from his family but he still
became a billionaire yeah you can
criticize him for all these things in
the world but I don't see you doing the
work he did to make it not only that I
became a president of the United States
yeah I love that one eat when he said
like I ran for public office one time
and I became the president the United
States but everyone's laughing and I'm
like it's a funny man funny guy
yep Kanye West he's got a lot of people
who look at him like he grew up in
Chicago he got the talent he worked hard
he succeeded and that success resonant
to people because there are a lot of
people who say I want to be like him you
know remember what what was it like the
American dream was to be Donald Trump is
that a real quote it was in different
rap rap songs for a long time yeah you
know just be to be be like Trump get how
many people's insane see his lifestyle
and they want that that you know you
know it shows look it we had the show
lifestyle of the rich and the famous
yeah then we had cribs people love to
look at the extravagance and the success
of wealthy famous people you know but a
lot of these people strive to be that
they want to figure it out they want
that dream Donald Trump came to these
people and said look at me and my golden
toilets you elect me and I'll make sure
everybody's got a golden toilet from sea
to shining sea
I'm exaggerating but he said he'd boost
the economy and he did yeah and then I
talked to so many people who said the
economy was better than ever I'm not
exaggerating when I say this I went to a
furniture store and I was buying some
furniture this is this table that we're
using right now yeah and the lady was I
was talking to her and she hasn't what I
did I said we do a political podcast and
then the conversation got into politics
and she basically said I don't know
about you know too much of that stuff
what I do know is this has been the best
year of my life in terms of income Wow
I'm like really goes it's crazy she's
like then the numbers are just know
people are buying stuff everybody's the
economy is great
I heard that over and over again from
various people when we had we had
contractors coming to do some work they
were like it's been amazing for us just
were overbooked I was trying to get a
mini-ramp built before this one and
every contract I called was like we're
booked up man were booked up for six
months and
man the economy's to good-good of
economy I don't think that that exists
what - bit of it too good for look when
I'm trying to hire someone to build
something and I gotta wait six yes
actually I could you better get my
camera so I said to the guy who's like
can I pay you extra like I understand
the demand is through the worth roof
what if we just up the you know the cost
it's like I'm locked in man I can't do
it well good thing you you you hired a
carpenter well so it landed at little do
they know I'm a carpenter I ordered I
ordered a prefab ramp
meaning they manufacture it in a
facility and then ship the pallets out
nothing like the big boxes yeah and then
I hired to some local handyman to come
in and it's like really really simple
instructions so you don't need an actual
you know carpenter builder or anything
like that yeah yeah the economy was
great
so if Kanye West steps up he's gonna
have a lot of people who are just like I
want to be like him yep and they're
gonna vote for him no matter what you
know he's he is he is a famous celebrity
who has proven his own success he's he's
a he's a billionaire right I don't know
about that but honey
yeah Kanye's another billionaire
president I don't know so here's what I
mean when I say I would vote for Kanye I
saw him come out and talk about helping
the American workers setting up a
factory in this country to produce his
shoes I think here awesome
I didn't know that actions leakes
actions speak louder than words awesome
and that alone means you know the the
door is open I'm not saying it's a
guarantee not for him not for Trump not
for anybody but if it comes down to 2024
and you got like you know Kanye West
running on some ticket and he's got a
very Pro America help the workers help
the middle class and he talks about
certain you know more moderate liberal
policies as a Chicago urban liberal he's
got a strong platform for a landslide
victory yeah right I agree I think you
would win huge numbers
I honestly I'm I would think he is
serious about 2024 I think so I think
it's it's serious love that when he was
like what you laughing at yeah yeah yeah
and it's like because he's probably
serious yeah he said on stage is like so
when I run for president 2024 I'm one
house laughing he goes you know what you
laughing at I'm like president Kanye and
it's funny to see so many people
offended by
they're like it really is idiocracy of
Kanye West gets elected it's like dude
look back in time yeah you apparently
don't know about some of our presidents
man or the fact that they know him yeah
they think that they know who he is
just because he's a celebrity on a
pedestal that everyone can see but you
just you don't know him
I just learned something about him my
quick google search to make sure that
wasn't telling a billionaire he owns
almost $300,000 worth of livestock did
you know that why he's a farmer yeah I
don't know yeah I was like what what
kind of life is that I know he's a
billionaire though right yeah he is he
is yeah Kanye West yeah you know what's
really offensive to me is how the left
runs away with conspiracy theories and
never gets called out for it you get one
like I'll tell you what I did there's a
there was an article from The Washington
Post that said could kovat have broken
out of a lab and it talked about the
south china was like south beijing
university where they said that they
were researching bats and that's where
kovin may have you know merchants from
the bats in the lab they escaped not
that it was manufactured and I get all
of a sudden these far leftist screaming
Tim pulls a conspiracy theorist because
I read The Washington Post article on it
but left right now high-profile leftists
are screaming that Kanye West and Trump
are conspiring to steal the black vote
away from Biden Wow which is racist and
insane on its face could you imagine
this I'm just this the rest of my
picture and I love this image it's like
a thunderstorm and like a car pulls up
until I Cassie critique or adore like a
tunnel to the White House and Kanye like
is like rushing out with a bunch of
secrets you know Secret Service agents
and they open the door
they bring him into a dark room where
like someone turns on a lamp and it's
Trump and Kanye and Trump's like this
meeting is off the record
never happened no recordings and then
Kanye polical folder yo here's a plan
he's a plan y'all he opens it up and
then it's like run for president all the
black people vote for Kanye Biden loses
Trump wins I'm like do they think - I
know it's silly but like do they
actually think Kanye called Trump and I
was like hey Trump I'm gonna help you
win by running to steal the votes away
from Biden
that's insane even if it was just Kanye
West calling Trump to do it or you know
it's way more plausible that that Kanye
just is a
supporter which they have been known to
of course b-bros and Kanye was hanging
out with Ilan and they're just like man
we keep I'm just gonna I'm gonna do this
I'm glad it out there probably I was
like probably they probably smoked up
together just you know making fun of
stuff and Kanye's like what if I said I
ran for president no no he was like yes
they're sitting there both baked yeah
Kanye goes yo Ilan you know I'm running
for president
and eelain's like shut up man you're not
really running for president and then
and then kind of like yo I'm serious bro
and he goes then tweet it say you're
doing it yeah right now you I'm even in
the meme Lord that is like that's why
this is the truest meme that I've ever
done hanging out yeah so orange grows so
so that many tweets then Ilan's I I got
your back buddy yeah sitting next to
each other laughing to billionaire
totally man somebody there's a funny
post where someone was like a sick joke
playing on the American people by
billionaires and I'm like okay well well
oh well like isn't that what the
mainstream media is must laughing and
joking about him running and tweeting it
I was like you're gonna take it to a
dark place I think it's funny you know
man it's really crazy when you see Elon
you know coming out Kanye coming out so
many people when you start to listen
which op has to say who are these people
who are so terrified of a Trump second
election I don't know
I honestly I feel like everyone who
screeches at me on Facebook I just want
to ask them have they ever actually
listened to any of Trump's speeches any
one have you listened to one of his
speeches no and I have a feeling none of
them have I think none of them here's
Mike Ortiz my question he's my question
do you support Joe Biden and the
establishment Democrats yes or no
I'd be willing to bet overwhelmingly the
answer is no all right
here's my response to that so you have
an option right now to re-import prett
establishment Democrats or let the bowl
rampage around inside the ivory tower
for another four years
do you really think the world will end
in four years
Trump if you really think Trump is all
that bad
then don't you think four years of Trump
will prove the corporate Democrats wrong
and then the progressives will be able
to win if Trump destroys everything and
you really believe he's the worst and
you don't have an opportunity to get
your progressive or Bernie in right now
voting for Biden will put a band-aid
over the wound and they'll all go back
to sleep
mm-hmm but if Trump really is that bad
no anyway it won't put a bandit sorry I
can't I can't just let that flow he'll
he's trying to keep the wound open right
and they're literally holding the wound
open and saying this is what the world
is like what I'm saying everyone is like
this what I'm saying is the
establishment Democrats are failing
putting them back in power allows them
to store up their strength and their
base and prevent progressives from
actually winning right however if you
really believe Donald Trump is the worst
ever give another four years let him
prove he's the worst and then you come
back and say see we warned you America
now it's time to get off progressive and
right and if you don't agree with that
and you think Trump is the best you vote
for true in the end the best bet for any
populist left or right at this point is
a vote for Trump voting for Biden gives
the establishment the reins again and
they will shore up all their defenses
they will bring in all of their cronies
into intelligence agencies and make sure
no one ever shuts them out again yeah
they fell off base here's here's I don't
you imagine American Gladiators that
show love that where they would fight
with their big Q tips awesome here's an
app and shoot tennis balls at 16 the
establishment was fighting with Trump
and Trump whacked one of the
establishment guys in the face and he's
he's whoa whoa had to fall off you know
he's lost his balance you vote for him
he gets his balance back he shows up as
defenses and no one else can come in
after the fact if you let Trump knock
him off and fall to the pit they're out
you can claim Trump is worse than you
know and the worst thought for B but I
can't believe there are people actually
advocating for for Biden Trump you know
and I think the problem is the
propaganda for sure that's because the
Trump is not that bad no he's great by
the economy no new Waris no he's doing
conservatism you got the judges that's
the big risk for for liberals like
moderate liberals is
that all the judges the Conservatives
are winning over this one I'll tell you
what man if I have a choice between
far-left revolutionary judges and a
conservative judge I'm making the
conservative wife I'm I'm not a
revolutionary yeah I'm a reformist
and I will take I will I will take slow
progress over total collapse in the
burning down of everything because I do
love this country Liddy agrees yes and
so that's that you know it's the fault
of the far left because moderate regular
I think regular Americans your average
person is like reluctantly pro-choice
they're like okay well we don't want to
celebrate say like abortion but there's
a rights issue there's health issues and
we have to make sure we do this fairly
right but that's gone it's completely
gone that argument isn't actually now on
the moderate Republican side of the
argument
you've got the pro-life and then you've
got the pro-life with some exceptions
then you have the left where it's like
total abortion Anytime Anywhere yeah
that's ridiculous
and so regular people are like I guess
I'll take some losses if it means not
burning everything in the ground mm-hmm
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you